[Music]
in all times and places in our history
human beings have wondered
where did we come from what's our place
in the world
what happens to us after we die
religions are systems of belief that
have developed and evolved over time in
response to these
and other eternal mysteries driven by
the feeling that some questions can only
be answered by faith
and based on an intuition that there's
something greater than ourselves a
higher power we must answer to or some
source we all spring from
and to which we must return
hinduism means the religions of india
it's not a single religion but rather a
variety
of related beliefs and spiritual
practices
it dates back five millennia to the time
of krishna
a man of such virtue that he became
known as an avatar of visnu
an incarnation of the god in human form
he taught that all life follows karma
the law of cause and effect
and our job is to do our duty or dharma
according to our place in society
without worrying how things turn out
when we die we're reincarnated into a
new body
if we followed our dharma and did our
proper duty in our past life
we get good karma which sends our soul
upward in the social scale
our rebirth into the next life is thus
determined by what we do in this one
the wheel of rebirths is called samsara
it's possible for a very holy person to
lead a life with enough good karma
to escape the wheel this escape is
called muksha
hinduism teaches that everything is one
the whole universe is one transcendent
reality called brahman
and there's just one brahman but many
gods within it
and their roles aspects and forms differ
according to various traditions
brahma is the creator visnu is the
preserver who sometimes takes on human
form
and shiva is the transformer or lord of
the dance
durga is the fiercely protective divine
mother
ganesha has an elephant head and is the
wise patron
of success hinduism is the third largest
religion in the world
and although most hindus live in india
they can be found on
every continent one billion strong
now let's travel west across deserts and
mountains to the fertile crescent about
4 000 years ago
judaism began with god calling abraham
and sarah to leave mesopotamia
and migrate to the land of canaan in
return for their faith in the one true
god
a revolutionary concept in the
polytheistic world of that time
they would have land and many
descendants
from this promise came the land of
israel and the chosen people
but staying in that land and keeping
those people together was going to be
very difficult
the israelites were enslaved in egypt
but god freed them with the help of the
prophet moses
who received the ten commandments and
later hundreds more
they conquered the promised land but
could only keep it for a few hundred
years
israel sits at a crossroads through
which many armies marched over the
centuries
and in the year 70 the romans destroyed
the temple in their capital
jerusalem so the religion transformed
itself from a temple religion with
sacrifices and priests to a religion of
the book
because of this judaism is a faith of
symbolism
reverence and deep meanings tied to the
literature of its history
the many sacred scriptures make up the
hebrew bible or tanach
and hundreds of written discussions and
interpretations are contained in an
expansive compendium of deeper meanings
called the talmud jews find rich
symbolic meaning in daily life
at the passover meal every item on the
menu symbolizes an aspect of the escape
from slavery
the importance of growing up is
emphasized when young people reach the
age of bar and bat mitzvah
ceremonies during which they assume
responsibility for their actions and
celebrate the weaving of their own lives
into the faith history
and texts of the jewish people there are
14 million jews in the world today
6 million in israel which became
independent following the horrors of
genocide in world war ii
and 5 million in the united states
but now let's go back 2500 years and
return to india
where buddhism began with a young prince
named siddhartha on the night he was
conceived his mother queen maya
is said to have been visited in her
sleep by a white elephant
who entered her side ten months later
prince siddhartha was born into a life
of luxury
venturing forth from his sheltered
existence as a young man
he witnessed the human suffering that
had been hidden from him and immediately
set out to investigate its sources
why must people endure suffering must we
reincarnate through hundreds of lives
at first he thought the problem was
attachment to material things so he gave
up his possessions
he became a wandering beggar which he
discovered certainly made him no happier
then he overheard a music teacher
telling a student don't tighten the
string too much it will break
but don't let it go too slack or it will
not sound
in a flash he realized that looking for
answers at the extremes was a mistake
the middle way between luxury and
poverty seemed wisest
and while meditating under a bodhi tree
the rest of the answer came to him
all of life abounds with suffering it's
caused by selfish craving for one's own
fulfillment at the expense of others
following an eight-step plan can teach
us to reduce that craving
and thus reduce the suffering on that
day siddhartha became
the buddha the enlightened one not the
only one but the first one
the buddhist plan is called the
eightfold path and though it is not easy
to follow
it has pointed the way for millions to
enlightenment which is what buddhahood
means a state of compassion insight
peace and steadfastness from the time he
got up from under that tree to the
moment of his death as an old man
the buddha taught people how to become
enlightened write speech
write goals a mind focused on what is
real and a heart
focused on loving others many buddhists
believe in god or gods but
actions are more important than beliefs
there are nearly a billion buddhists in
the world today
mostly in east south east and south asia
two thousand years ago in judaism's
promised land
christianity was born just as hindus
call krishna
god in human form christians say the
same thing about jesus
and christianity grew out of judaism
just as buddhism grew out of hinduism
the angel gabriel was sent by the god of
abraham to ask a young woman named mary
to become the mother of his son the son
was jesus
raised as a carpenter by mary and her
husband joseph
until he turned 30 when he began his
public career as the living word of god
less interested in religiousness than
injustice and mercy
jesus healed the sick in order to draw
crowds and then taught them
about his heavenly father affectionate
forgiving
and attentive then he would invite
everyone to a common table to illustrate
his
kingdom of god outcasts sinners and
saints all eating together
he had only three years before his
unconventional wisdom got him into
trouble
his enemies had him arrested and he was
executed by rome in the standard means
by
which rabble-rousers were put to death
crucifixion
but shortly after he was buried women
found his tomb empty and quickly spread
word
convinced that he had been raised from
the dead
the first christians described his
resurrected appearances
inspiring confidence that his message
was true the message
love one another as i have loved you
christians celebrate the birth of jesus
in december at christmas
and his suffering death and resurrection
during holy week in the spring
in the ceremony of baptism a washing
away of sin and welcoming into the
christian community
recall jesus's own baptism when he left
his life as a carpenter
in the rite of communion christians eat
the bread and drink the wine blessed as
the body and blood of jesus
recalling jesus's last supper there are
two billion christians worldwide
representing almost a third of the
world's people
islam began 1400 years ago with a man of
great virtue
meditating in a mountain cave in the
arabian desert
the man was muhammad he was visited by a
divine messenger
again the angel gabriel in arabic jibril
delivering to him the words of allah the
one god of abraham
in the next few years more and more
messages came and he memorized and
taught them
the verses he recited were full of wise
sayings beautiful rhymes
and mysterious metaphors but muhammad
was a merchant not a poet
many agreed the verses were indeed the
words of god and these believers became
the first muslims
the word muslim means one who surrenders
meaning
a person who submits to the will of god
a muslim's five most important duties
are called the five pillars
shahada muslims declare publicly
there is no other god but allah
and muhammad is his final prophet salat
they pray five times a day facing mecca
zakat
every muslim is required to give two or
three percent of their net worth to the
poor
saum they fast during daylight hours for
the lunar month
of ramadan to strengthen their willpower
and their reliance on god
and hajj once in a lifetime every muslim
who is able must make a pilgrimage to
the holy city of mecca
rehearsing for the time when they will
stand before god to be judged worthy or
unworthy of eternal life with him the
words of god
revealed to the prophet over 23 years
are collected in the quran
which literally translates into the
recitation
muslims believe it to be the only holy
book free of human corruption
it's also considered by many to be the
finest work of literature in the arabic
language
islam is the world's second largest
religion practiced by over one and a
half billion muslims around the globe
religion has been an aspect of culture
for as long as it has existed
and there are countless variations of
his practice
but common to all religions is an appeal
for meaning beyond the empty vanities
and lowly realities of existence beyond
sin
suffering and death beyond
fear and beyond ourselves
you